[Music]
foreign
hey folks welcome to the 145th Dark
Horse podcast live stream from our
makeshift temporary not quite a studio
Diggs I know there was some question in
the chat as to whether or not our studio
would be set up for this live stream and
I have to say there's much delightful
about living where we now live but it is
slow going getting things accomplished
um electrical work etc so it's going to
be some time before we're on our our
permanent new digs but I think it will
be well worth it and thanks for bearing
with us
that's right so you're Brett Weinstein
I'm Heather Hein here we are top of the
hour Dark Horse
uh next week we will be coming to you a
day late on Sunday and the following
week we're not going to have a live
stream at all but in the interim Brett
has at least three maybe more uh guest
podcasts already scheduled or recorded
and a couple of them at least are gonna
be on fire so stay tuned for those the
ones that are not on fire off the hook
all right all right and I sure
absolutely yep yeah
uh we have we're gonna start with
Logistics housekeeping I guess uh check
out our book Hunter gatherer's guide oh
we are going to have a q a this week as
we usually do after you know starting 10
15 minutes after we finish this main
live stream you can ask questions
starting now at darkhorsesubmissions.com
we try to get to as many as we can and
it's you know it's kind of an ask ask me
anything
if you're watching on YouTube we're also
streaming live on on Odyssey and that's
where the chat is uh YouTube continues
to have us demonetized and um
and odyssey wouldn't do any such thing
so here we are
um yes also on YouTube uh where if
they're showing you ads uh that we
aren't reading ourselves that's them
making money off of us not us making
money off of us so
I think I need to make a correction okay
uh you suggested that the Q a wasn't ask
me anything obviously it's not quite
that I would say uh these are inquiries
they're inquiring of us and really
anything can be inquired making it an
eua
rather than an AMA do you think inquire
is 12 with an e
wow is it not
all right well I guess I'm not going to
be the official speller of the Dark
Horse pod what was the U in the imagined
anyway I'm pretty sure that one does
have a u in it somewhere
boy there was never any chance that
answer she'll spell her
yes or in fact anything beer Hefe once
yes of a small tropical island but
official speller no no not the official
speller
maybe a British spelling Inquirer am I
incorrect that the national and also not
spelled with an E also incorrect
incorrect incorrect yeah that one I got
it's better than I the national Inquirer
is not spelled with an E it is it is
I think that's like part of the joke I
don't know I don't know well they got me
that was uh that was a very long oh my
God a long Con on their part but anyway
they did yeah they're just that good yes
I I think I want I want to redo on all
my correspondence that has involved the
word inquire well I'm super pleased
actually that you're like attempted and
almost
um as you hoisted on your own batard
over spelling
right yeah defined petard
um it's a sword now it's it's an item of
clothing it's no it's a it's it's a is
it a it's a it's not a gauntlet what is
it it's a
I don't know it's a state of mind no
it's not it's not a state of mind I
don't know what it is either I just
thought I would hoist you on yours
all right back to business indeed we
have a store uh it's pretty great uh
darkhorsestore.org go there to find lots
of cool stuff and we'll be putting some
new stuff up there soon I believe
including what's up there already the
most recent Edition is Keep Portland
Weird all caps the acronym obviously
Keep Portland Weird Western educated
industrialized Rich Democratic we are no
longer in Portland but we still have
many connections there and it is um it
is not staying weird enough it's not no
it's not no The Good the good kind of
weird is not uh it's coming apart
basically yeah it is it's really it's
rumbling it's really terrible it's
beautiful amazing City with such
potential yeah yeah
um well I have I post every week at
natural
selections.substack.com this week I
wrote what the girls do and I'm going to
read a tiny bit from that uh during this
podcast but I encourage you to go there
free subscribers get almost all of the
text for free I do audio reads for
paying subscribers there that's natural
selections. stack.com and a reminder as
I've already said we are supported by
our audience we are uh we appreciate you
subscribing liking sharing videos that
you see on Odyssey on YouTube on Spotify
or the clips at Darkhorse podcast Clips
or we have channels on both Odyssey and
YouTube and
um you know really if if you can choose
not to watch on YouTube we encourage
that because YouTube isn't doing us any
favors and they are in fact profiting
off of us without cutting us into the
proceeds from our own work and obviously
meddling with our numbers whether that
is by keeping people from watching or
not reporting honestly how many people
are subscribing people highly likely
they are not uh they are not honest
actors nope and uh you know there's a
lot of that going on around isn't there
uh you can join one of our patreons we
are still on patreon for now uh when you
get act where you get access to private
monthly q and A's mine or um more
intimate conversations with Brett his
and you
cannot either of them get access to the
Discord server where you can engage in
honest conversations about difficult
topics during a book club and wine with
virtual happy hours karaoke all the
different types of people you might hope
to run into in any Metropolitan City if
particular demographic is what you're
after you're likely to find it on that
Discord server because you don't get
canceled for a look at the wrong way or
thinking the wrong way there
for anything and of course we have
sponsors to whom we are indebted we are
grateful that they stand by Dark Horse
and we are very choosy in who we are
willing to have as sponsor so if you
hear us reading ads from our own mouths
you can you can know for sure that we
are vouching for those products so we
have three at the top of the hour as
usual without further Ado here we go
[Music]
our first sponsor this week is relief
band a product that can help with nausea
under ancient circumstances nausea was
generally a useful signal that something
was off you had eaten something you
shouldn't have or were near something
emanating a bad smell itself a signal
that you should not go near it in
modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities you should not
always choose to Simply erase discomfort
like nausea whenever we feel it
that said solomonarity creates nausea
that does no good at all travel sickness
for instance can be agonizing and relief
would be lovely enter relief band relief
band is an anti-nausea wristband that
has been clinically proven to relieve
and prevent nausea associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
chemotherapy and more relief band is 100
drug free and can be used for as long as
you need it developed over 20 years ago
it is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting and there are zero side effects
and now they have relief Grand Sport
which is waterproof and features
interchangeable bands and has an
extended battery life we asked a friend
who does suffer from frequent nausea as
we do not to try it out here is her
testimonial
I used to have nausea on a near daily
basis from both anxiety and the need to
take regular medication relief bound
relieves my nausea in less than three
minutes without the side effects I was
experiencing from anti-nausea medication
it has entirely changed my life for the
better she says so if you've got nausea
from anxiety or car or seasickness or
something else that you cannot otherwise
disable consider relief band relief band
makes a great gift for any time of year
right now they've got an exclusive offer
just for Dark Horse listeners go to
reliefband.com and use Pro bone code
Darkhorse to receive 20 off plus free
shipping and no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee that's r e l i e f
b a n d.com and use our promo code
darker Dark Horse for twenty percent off
plus free shipping
our second sponsor today is element
that's lmnt element is an electrolyte
drink mix that has everything you need
and nothing you don't it's got a lot of
salt 1000 milligrams of sodium 200
milligrams of potassium and 60 of
magnesium but it has no sugar no
coloring no artificial ingredients no
gluten and no fillers electrolytes
facilitate hundreds of functions in the
body including the conduction of nerve
impulses hormonal regulation and
nutrient absorption elements
electrolytes can help prevent eliminate
headaches muscle cramps and
sleeplessness we have now heard from
several friends about how much they like
element as as do we for themselves or in
some cases for the physically
hard-working men in their lives they
drink it every day and feel better doing
so
When you sweat the primary electrolyte
loss is sodium athletes can lose up to 7
grams per day element is formulated to
help anyone with their electrolyte needs
and is perfectly suited to folks
following your keto low carb or Paleo
Diet
element isn't just for athletes though
anyone being active may find they
benefit from element even drinking a few
glasses of wine can leave you depleted
an element can help if you're feeling
depleted or dehydrated drink water and
consider element as well
right now element is offering our
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try all eight flavors
or share element with a salty friend
I really think that should say a not yet
salty friend yes they're not salty
enough right yeah an undersalted friend
go salt your friends
get yours at drinkelement.com Darkhorse
this deal is only available through our
link you must go to
d-r-i-n-klmnt.com
Darkhorse element offers no questions
asked refunds as well try it totally
risk-free if you don't like it share it
with that not yet salty enough friend
and they will give you your money back
no questions asked you have nothing to
lose
all right our final sponsor this week is
all form a company that makes terrific
custom sofas for live streaming and much
else we like them so much that we have
two of them Heather is now going to
demonstrate the proper use of the
all-form sofa for those of you who are
listening on an audio only platform she
is now demonstrating the use of the sofa
and she looks very comfortable as does
the dog as does the dog I don't know if
I look comfortable but I am also
attempting to demonstrate proper use of
the sofa you look great man well thank
you
um what makes this sofa terrific for a
fraction of the cost of traditional
sofas you can customize size layout
Fabric and color
they do armchairs and love seats all the
way up to an eight seat sectional this
is the easiest way to customize a sofa
and the quality is fantastic furthermore
they are beautiful and comfortable roomy
and adaptable all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home free and
fast and assembly is easy we started
with one beautiful sectional all-form
sofa in whiskey leather which you can
now observe
it's soft and supple and warm unlike a
lot of leather we pile on it to watch
movies some evenings it looks gorgeous
and is incredibly inviting and
comfortable a rare combination also some
listeners asked if all formed sofas hold
up to pets why yes Maddie they do
um
no she really doesn't care um the
leather that all form uses is about 20
thicker than typical Furniture leather
and it shows nowhere despite the fact
that both cats and the dog lie on the
couch many evenings and if you prefer
fabric all form Fabrics are three and a
half times more durable than the
industry standard for heavy duty Fabrics
so their Fabrics are going to hold up
really well with pets also finally they
offer a forever warranty literally
forever find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
Darkhorse all form is offering 20 off
all orders to our listeners at
allform.com Darkhorse
step up your sofa game today
all right we did not start at the top of
the hour by talking about what we're
going to talk about no maybe we should
just talk about we're going to talk
about rather than uh talking about first
what we're about to be talking about yes
we skipped the abstract we did all right
we did uh allow me to begin sure is that
okay perfect all right have you seen uh
the Jon Stewart interview of the
Attorney General of Arkansas I have not
but I do know who Jon Stewart is yes who
is Jon Stewart
I was not expecting that question uh
well Jon Stewart is obviously a uh comic
and all-around likable guy who became uh
incredibly famous as the host of The
Daily Show coincidentally with Jon
Stewart yeah he was he was the original
host of The Daily Show for gosh I want
to say 20 years but I don't know if it
was around for that long and maybe
that's wrong but a good long time yes
and um
and he was he was a favorite of many on
on the left at least and I I thought
that he had a fairly good
um following across across the aisle as
well but maybe I don't know maybe maybe
that's not right
um but he's and he retired from The
Daily Show and I don't know became a
former or something I think like which
just went out of the public eye for a
while and is now back
with a show whose name I've forgotten uh
it is it's a great name yeah it is um
it's uh the problem with John the
problem with Jon Stewart which I thought
that all of the uh tweets about his his
new interview were accounts that didn't
like him because frankly the video that
that is being shown that he's proudly
displaying on his new show the problem
with Jon Stewart
unfortunately reveals at least a problem
with Jon Stewart and it's it's a it's
it's not great so you're you're
flinching well I mean we will get there
let's let's get to the the particular
interview so uh we don't yet in the
setup have an ability for me to show uh
what's on my screen uh so I'm just going
to summarize he interviews he's
interviewing the Attorney General of
Arkansas Leslie Rutledge uh who's a
republican woman and he asks her why she
would go against the medical consensus
uh from these reputable medical
associations you know it's uh the
American Medical Association the
American Academy of Pediatrics the
endocrine Society
um why she would have uh moved to move
to have go into law uh going against the
medical consensus
that apparently this consensus being
transiting children is totally fine and
I'm using
am I using trans as a intransitive verb
is that possible an intransigent verb
yes
um but yeah so Arkansas has said
actually no you got to be an adult
before you can have any of these
procedures done to you before you can go
on puberty blockers before you can have
cross-x hormones before you can have
surgery to have healthy body parts
removed or created out of other flesh
which is which are the three major
medical interventions that the medical
community is currently in many places uh
just seemingly quite excited about and
fine with and in this interview the
Attorney General of Arkansas is back on
her heels and she's not a scientist and
she doesn't have all of her chief of
papers with her in this interview and uh
doesn't have an answer to his questions
you know which doctors did you did you
talk to and you know why would you go
against medical consensus
but he says you know Joan Stewart
Compares a child declaring themselves
trans to a child being diagnosed with
cancer
he says if the AMA if the American
Medical Association uh says okay with
this type of cancer that your child has
been diagnosed with you really need
chemotherapy would you as the Attorney
General of the state of Arkansas ever
think to uh to say actually we're not
going to allow that until you're an
adult
and you know the correct response there
is John uh
the belief of a child that they are not
the sex that they were born to is not
the same as a diagnosis of cancer
it's a fundamentally and totally
different thing in what way in a lot of
ways one of them is that cancer is not a
social construct okay you are the sex
that you were born very few people have
a very unfortunate and deeply held and
long-held sense that they would be
better off presenting to the world as
the sex that they were not born as as
adults if they choose to transition to
presenting to the world as the sex that
they are not
they're free to do so
it is a social condition
that it's not the same thing as cancer
now that doesn't even get into whether
or not what the AMA or the um
American Academy Pediatrics is currently
recommending for particular childhood
cancers is 100 obviously the right thing
just because they're recommending it
they'll get things wrong that's the
nature of science that's the nature of
medicine so a
don't you dare compare a child declaring
himself a girl or herself a boy to a
diagnosis of cancer and B the idea that
authorities who have been respected and
are currently making mistakes across the
board are the only Arbiters of Truth
well that is the error of the modern era
isn't it it's the error of the modern
era this is exactly what we're doing we
are pretending that science doesn't
exist that Authority is what exists and
Authority is now a replacement for
Science and that is the error that Jon
Stewart makes in this interview and I
have a few more things to say but I'm
sure you want to jump in here yeah well
I wanted to just point out that there
are there are genuinely difficult
questions in this neighborhood this
isn't one right what you do when a
parent does not believe in so-called
Western medicine or is you know
religiously prohibited from employing it
and they have a child sick with a
curable disease right that's is a
genuinely difficult question because
really you know children are children
for a reason and their parents are
supposed to look out for their interests
and to the extent that a parent has a
belief system that prevents the um you
know the treatment of a disease that is
survivable because of a relationship
with a spirit world that we cannot test
or verify or any of those things you
know that's difficult
in the case where hey we just know too
much about this right we know that lots
of people have a period of gender
dysphoria that just simply clears up
with time and even to the extent that
there is a real argument if you're one
of the tiny number of people who are
actually trans that actually
transitioning early is a good thing to
do the problem is we don't know who is
really truly trans and who is suffering
from a temporary sense of dysphoria and
therefore the idea that if you're just
very compelled that this is where you
are that you can transition with the
help of modern medicine that is
um an abuse of the doctor-patient
relationship and as you allude to
at this moment we can see that medicine
is not serving us well it is not giving
us advice that is good about what we
should and shouldn't do and in fact it
has been drafted into a political
campaign to portray certain treatments
as good even as the evidence mounts that
they are in fact net negative yes so a
point to which we have talked and we
will come back to you today
yes but just
what is the reasonable thing to do in a
world where trans exists yes trans
people often have a strong indication of
this early in life that many of the
people who think they have a strong
indication in fact turn out not to be
permanently in this state what is the
correct thing to do the correct thing to
do is to act with caution what does
caution look like it looks like not
making permanent changes those changes
include as we've discussed frequently
hormonal changes surgical changes these
are things that shouldn't be done
because reversing them is
um
not possible yeah and fully possible and
despite what some medical organizations
still contend uh you can't just halt
puberty and then restart it without any
effects that's simply not true and
anyone who gave any thought to what the
human organism is would have understood
that from the beginning
so here's a quote from Stuart in this
interview with Rutledge the Attorney
General from Arkansas quote you're
suggesting that protecting children
means overriding the recommendations of
the American Medical Association the
American Academy of Pediatrics and the
endocrine Society
so I would counter
uh
Jon Stewart with this on what basis are
those three organizations overriding
hundreds of millions of years of
evolution
where did they get their Authority
Authority is not the basis on which
science works but at the very least
organizations that are pretending to be
medical and therefore ought to be
scientific in nature need to be
considering what it is that we are
we are organisms that have been evolving
on this planet for billions of years we
have been mammals for over a hundred
million
ish something like that and
our hormonal systems are that ancient
they're in fact older but at the the
vertebrate hormonal systems are are
older than that and the idea that people
can come in and say ah it's fashionable
now to believe children when they say
they're a boy a girl who says they're a
boy but not a girl who says she's a
turtle maybe it's just because we don't
have the facility yet to turn someone
into a turtle but we can make you kind
of look like a boy so let's do it this
is insane so I'm actually going to read
the first just couple paragraphs from my
um Natural Selections this week if I may
this is called what do girls do
subtitle is girls become women
there was an eight-year-old girl who
likes to play in streams and look under
rocks for squirmy Critters she not only
knows how to throw a ball but enjoys
doing it she loves math and logic and
has no interest in dolls or dresses she
will grow up to be a woman
because that's what girls do
there was another eight-year-old girl
who likes to give tea parties for her
stuffed animals she likes to dance all
the dances often other often with other
girls who like to do the same thing she
loves to read and has no interest in
trucks or Trails she will also grow up
to be a woman because again that's what
girls do
one of these girls may want to be an
astronaut the other a chef or a mother
or a lawyer an actress a race car driver
are all of these desires equally likely
among girls they are not
girls are likely to want some things
more than others but guess what the
girls who aren't girly are still girls
you can tell in part by the fact that
they grow up to be women because that's
what girls do
sex isn't assigned at Birth sex is
observed at Birth
so of the three organizations that Jon
Stewart keeps coming back to
I spent a little bit of time on their on
their sites the American Association of
Pediatrics site seems to be in the
middle of maybe trying to
put a bunch of stuff behind
um
behind walls so I'm not going to spend
any time there the endocrine Society has
posted a number of things including its
2017 quote gender dysphoria slash gender
incongruence guidelines resources
and
um
the second of two essential points that
they post in this again I cannot show my
screen but this is again 2017 uh gender
dysphoria gender incongruence guidelines
from the endocrine Society
the second essential point that they
make what they're calling essential
points is as follows gender dysphoric
slash gender incongruent persons should
receive a safe and effective hormone
regimen that will suppress the body's
sex hormone secretion determined at
Birth and manifested at puberty and
maintain levels of sex story steroids
within the normal range for the person's
affirm to gender
that's incoherent
and it aligns it it is trying to point
out that actually what you are born as
is what your body proceeds to to make
you out to be and we now have the
technology to get in the way of that to
some degree not fully and not without a
lot of cost but
people should receive a safe and effect
of hormone regimen that will suppress
the body's sex hormone secretion
determined at Birth and manifested at
puberty
your six hormones are not determined at
Birth
your sex isn't determined at Birth your
sex isn't assigned at Birth your sex
again is observed at Birth and it
doesn't just manifest at puberty it
manifests in utero and an early
toddlerhood and again uh in more
dramatic ways that everyone is familiar
with who's gone through it at puberty
but there's nothing about a doctor
having come in and said yeah you you you
it's like it's like they've imagined
it's like the Sorting Hat from Harry
Potter
what was their term for what happens at
Birth
it's it's incoherent it's an incoherent
sense I'm just gonna read the sentence
again because it really doesn't make
sense and this is again the essential
point the second essential point in the
guidelines that are still the standing
guidelines from 2017 on how we treat
gender uh gender what is their phrase
gender dysphoria slash gender
incongruence from the endocrine Society
one of the three main professional
organizations that Jon Stewart keeps
hammering
quote gender dysphoric gender
incongruent persons should receive a
safe and effective hormone regimen that
will suppress the body's sex hormone
secretion comma determined at Birth and
manifested at puberty comma and maintain
levels of sex stories within the normal
range for the person's affirmed gender
okay determined at Birth
this is a scientific slash medical
society that thinks anything about that
individual is determined at Birth there
you go that is a non-medical
non-scientific judgment that appears to
be a way of acknowledging that there is
something
inherent to this being but not wanting
to raise questions about whether or not
there is a being with rights prior to
birth having it to do with a completely
other discussion right this is insane
right what happens at Birth is that the
individual goes from inside another body
to the outside world that's what happens
at Birth nothing about hormones yeah the
lungs start working and there's some
balling and oh there's a lot of stuff
right it's an event for sure but it is
not a determinate event in the hormonal
life of this creature I mean once again
it's a post-modern view of humanity it's
uh a doctor a midwife a doula whatever
someone came in and said I pronounce you
a boy and there they made him a boy and
if a different Doula had come in or
Midwife or doctor whatever and said I
pronounce you but girl boom that person
would have been a girl not how it works
everyone knows it why are we letting
these people pretend and how is it that
the major medical organizations have
been so captured that now they've
confused one of one of what was once the
most important commenters on cultural
news of the day that the two exist to
resist the insanity and frankly the
child abuse that is happening is itself
anti-scientific you got it backwards
John you got it backwards well okay so I
want to come back then to what's going
on with John Stewart because I I quite
like the guy I have to say but this is
not the first place where we have seen
him wade into the issues of the modern
era
uh in a ham-fisted fashion so anyway I
want to point out a couple things here
one what we know and what anybody who
watches this podcast or a good number of
other podcast knows is that
organizations are being pressured
into saying things that violate their
original Mission right the ACLU is now a
threat to civil liberties because it has
embraced a political ideology but it
can't be because it still has the word
civil liberties in its name well so it
it can't but I want to I want to give
Jon Stewart his too a there's a reason
that he is what he is which is that he's
a very likable very smart guy my sense
is he's a very likable
he does and and he's also earned life's
equivalent of tenure where he now is so
wealthy that he doesn't really have to
worry about what happens to him he may
not like it if people say nasty things
about him but they can't touch him right
so the question is why is he not playing
a more useful role given what he is and
who he is and what we all think his
instincts are and the problem
is that if you have been again I don't
know how many years he was doing The
Daily Show but if you have had a gig in
which you are adored by millions and you
have a great deal of control over what
your show looks like if you've had that
sweet relationship with the universe
not entirely unlike the sweet
relationship that we had with our
teaching jobs right where we got to
write we got to decide what we wanted to
teach how we wanted to teach it nobody
was in a position to tell us
you know differently right that was a
pretty good deal if you have a deal like
that and then the world has changed and
it intrudes into your life you may not
understand that the ACLU has gone from
one of the you know the last fail-safes
protecting civil liberties to a threat
to civil liberties because of course it
still has the same looking website and
same acronym and all of that so what I
think is going on with Jon Stewart is he
has the sense that the world that he
more or less exited when he went into
that sweet gig of his is
can't have changed that much right the
ACLU can't be the inverse of the ACLU
right that would be crazy the you know
racist may have changed but it you know
the the nature of racism hasn't inverted
right right so if you come back out with
a sense that things must be sort of like
you remember
and then you try to make sense of
well who are the people who are being
oppressed because everybody's too
old-fashioned to accept you know the the
lot in life that biology has handed them
obviously trans people and I don't even
disagree with that I think it's even
true but the problem is if you think
trans people face a very difficult Road
based on some Quirk of biology
and you don't understand the trans
activists and trans people are actually
two different phenomena right and that
trans activism is now orders of
magnitude more people than actual trans
folks struggling with the difficulties
that that situation puts you in then you
think well all right these people need a
defense and I'm gonna come out and give
that defense and it can't be all that
unclear what that defense should be
let's just look what the Medical Science
says and then you end up with these
medical societies and you don't
understand that they've been captured by
something and even if they know better
they can't manage to say it publicly
because they'd be destroyed so if that
world
is just different enough from the one
that you last had to interact with then
you can't fathom how different things
are you can't see that in order to
figure out what medical science thinks
you can't go to the medical societies
okay yeah but all right
there's a reliance
on organizations conclusions
over thinking it through for yourself
what your own eyes tell you what your
own logic can reveal if you just think
carefully about it that's the way of
Science and that's the way that all of
us no matter what your degree is or is
not or what you call yourself or how bad
you think you were at logic or math or
whatever in school all of us
have the capacity for that level of
scientific Instinct I've made an
observation
I'm going to see if I can falsify it I'm
going to see if I can render it untrue
by anything else that I can find out in
the universe and if I can't
I'm going to continue to think that that
thing is true
even if the authorities come at me with
bludgeons and Hammers and pitchforks
and instead from Jon Stewart and as
we're going to see here definitely from
these organizations including the
American Medical Association what we
have is
we're sure
sorry my computer is threatening to shut
itself down I can't take it I can't take
it anymore
um
what we have from these organizations
and from the people who are parroting
them is we've done the work you don't
have to and in fact you can't we're not
going to let you get anywhere near
trying to do the work for yourself and
we're going to tell you you're engaging
in Miss dis malinformation whatever it
is
we've done it trust us
that's our job
and you know what that's never been the
job of anything on behalf of a populist
a populist all of us have to be able to
encourage to and actually feel
encouraged in and of our own selves
to question any pronouncements that come
down from such agencies and authorities
and having an argument be based entirely
on but they said it's not an argument so
and he's smarter than that of course he
that's that's my point he's smarter than
that but he's not engaging his intellect
in the right way to see it and frankly I
don't know that he's going to see this
or not but if he does he ought to look
at what you've revealed about the claim
by this Society of endocrinologists that
something endocrinologically important
is happening at Birth that couldn't have
been determined seven minutes before
right right he Jon Stewart knows enough
biology to look at that and say wait a
minute why is an endocrinological
Society claiming that birth is the
moment at which your hormones are chosen
and that that sentence that I read from
the endocrine society's 2017 report
which is its most modern report that I
found on their resources for gender
dysphoria
um they say they
say nothing it's like the most clear
they get right they don't they don't go
into anything about the sudden rise in
gender trans and transgender
identification
um whether this might be a symptom
whether this might be a symptom the
underlying cause for which should be
addressed as opposed to oh let's let's
facilitate the fantasy uh that your
experience that you are something you're
not that's not what doctors are supposed
to do so
several things are true one there's a
clue right here that something has gone
on with at least this one society and
our claim will be if you look at all of
them you're going to find the same
evidence you're going to find evidence
that these folks are speaking a
political truth and they are disguising
it as a scientific truth and the point
is what happened John well you had
societies that look they were always a
mixed bag right that's what happens when
people get together and they have a
certain amount of power to declare
things but what is supposed to be true
of these societies is that they are
supposed to be taking the information
which is scientifically generated and
the authority that they have is a
supposed to be limited right Authority
is not how science works and B it is
supposed to follow from what is
discovered through the scientific
process what has happened is that
somebody has taken the authority that
was earned through scientific study and
is now using that to broadcast something
else it it is a wolf in sheep's clothing
it is a trojan horse but the point is
you cannot go to the ACLU and find out
uh you know where civil liberties are
being threatened you cannot go to the
AMA and find out what the latest medical
science is telling us about your
well-being and how to cater to it right
you cannot go to
um you know the American Psychological
society and discover you know what the
state of uh gender science is that isn't
possible anymore and nobody is saying
that that's safe the absence of
functional societies that would allow us
to figure out what the Cutting Edge was
telling us but that's nonetheless where
we find ourselves and I would I would
offer one other piece of evidence that I
hope will trigger Jon Stewart to
reinvestigate his position
you and I have said frequently on
Darkhorse that not only is trans a real
phenomenon that a tiny number of people
exhibit but it is also an ancient
phenomenon which we know because it is
seen in many different cultures and the
distinction between what is being said
now right to have medical societies
saying that what naturally follows from
the needs of trans people is
intervention flies in the face of the
truly transportive position which is
look this is a real phenomenon that is
long-standing and exists in many if not
all cultures right the fact that these
medical societies are claiming something
very new some something uh very
aggressive in the intervention is
necessary to treat trans people
honorably flies in the face of the
history and pre-history of transness
which is not well understood but
nonetheless
Jon Stewart ought to be thinking well
wait a minute if it is true that
transness is ancient why is modern
technology necessary to treat trans
people well is this a mistake or is it
not a mistake and do these people have
any idea what the downstream
consequences of the interventions that
they are advocating are you know do they
have a plan for the large number of
people that we know experience dysphoria
early and end up with perfectly uh
standard gender identity later in life
right these are all really important
questions yeah and I think
um actually one of the points one more
point from this endocrine Society
document is that they they
say gender dysphoria slash gender
incongruence
and
gender dysphoria
is a sense that you uh
need to be presenting to the world as
the sex that you are not
gender incongruence
is a regressive idea from the 50s
frankly not that the Indian was calling
it then that if you're a tomboy or a a
girl who likes to do boy typical things
or if you're a boy who likes to do girl
typical things then that's gender
incongruence and you need medical
intervention to cure you of that now if
gender incongruence is being kind of
equilibrated with or equated with gender
dysphoria at least being lumped in here
that is a regressive nasty frankly not
at all until yesterday you know anything
close to a left-wing position this is
backwards this is anti-woman
anti-feminist anti-equality
anti-progress
for all of us who would like to be able
to have ourselves and our children and
our children's children make decisions
about how they want to be and and what
they want to do in the world based on
their proclivities and their
capabilities not based on the sex they
are
just because I
was a lot more like that first pair that
first girl in the paragraph of the piece
that I read in that second girl I was
much more likely to be you know come
home covered in dirt and want to talk
math then I want to have a tea party for
any of my friends doesn't mean I thought
I was a boy I wanted to be a boy doesn't
mean I should have been a boy certainly
doesn't mean someone should have come
along and said let's stop puberty for
you and see what you're going to turn
out to be nope
was a girl always gonna be a girl always
going to be coming into a woman and yes
some people who experience that
do turn out to be okay
very very very few of them do turn out
to be
trans
number
and a lot of them turn out to be
straight women or straight men who just
don't follow the stereotypes and the
idea that we're medicalizing not
following stereotypes is regressive as
[ __ ] yeah it is ultra regressive and
actually this ought to be the wake-up
call for a guy like Jon Stewart is the
obviously liberal Progressive
open-minded thing is what you are born
of does not require you to behave in any
particular way you should be free to
choose those things and we should not be
surprised if there are asymmetries and
what gets chosen by people of different
Sexes but you know how much better is
the world now that we you know that the
fact that you're born a girl doesn't
mean you can't uh aspire to be an
engineer right we all like that world
better right you do don't you Jon
Stewart so if if you like that world
better than the last thing you want to
see is this you know spasm of
reactionary gender nonsense where you
know we're gonna die diagnose you as
having a pathology that's in need of
medical intervention because you
manifest tendencies that didn't match
the color that your parents painted the
nursery that you spent your toddlerhood
in or whatever that's right
so um
switching slightly but following the
same line of thought I went to look at
the site for the American Medical
Association
which was a treat as you can imagine
one of the top articles oh so Zack I
sent to you and I um an email not not
yet but if if you can end up seeing that
link
don't show it just now it's gonna be the
next thing I want to link to
um because I didn't send you this one
one of the first articles on the AMA
site the American Medical Association
I sent it to uh yes I sent it both to
your your and dads at uh yeah
yeah so uh you could
you can send me something from an email
account that you would like me to send
it to but I will do that maybe we'll see
if this can work
um
let's see now I'm thrown by
where I was
okay so at the top of near the top of
the page the AMA we have a piece from
October 5th three days ago as we're live
streaming uh by the president of the AMA
a guy named Jack Resnick Jr MD and the
title of this piece is turning the tide
against medical disinformation will take
all of us
let me read you a couple bits from this
countering anti-science aggression
make no mistake the health of our
patients is put at risk by coordinated
well-resourced efforts to mislead the
public about medicine and science this
anti-science aggression as some have
called it not only undermined confidence
in the covid-19 vaccines but it has also
been used to widen existing divisions on
far-ranging issues such as access to
Safe reproductive care achieving Health
Equity and discrimination against
transgender patients
anti-science aggression undermine
confidence in the covid vaccines yes yes
what undermined the confidence in the
coveted vaccines is that they suck yeah
it was actually the covid-19 vaccines
that undermine the confidence and the
nonsense that was said about them ahead
of time which created which was the
actual misinformation the actual
misinformation so there's that okay
we know we can this again from the
relatively new president of the AMA
the American Medical Association we know
we can fight disinformation while
protecting our cherished First Amendment
principles we have no interest in
policing the open debate of debate of
ideas that has been the Cornerstone of
scientific advancement
but scientific discourse does not
include spreading dangerous known
falsehoods that farm that harm the
public health with the intent to deceive
we are disheartened that a very small
number of Physicians and health
professionals have been among the
loudest purveyors of false health
information about covid that's why the
AMA has called on State Medical boards
and Specialty accreditation boards to
respond swiftly when Physicians spread
disinformation violating the ethics of
our profession
it
yeah yeah exactly
um no that's um that is incredible I
thought so
the problem is
any rational person knows that we are
stuck with a predicament which is
you cannot know in advance what the
misinformation is that this is something
that sorts itself out over time the idea
can they hear themselves
I don't
it's hard to render you speechless it's
hard well I I'm trying to not burst a
blood vessel in my eye as my blood
pressure goes up hearing their
ridiculous portrayal where they are in
fact perfectly ready to defend uh
freedom of speech as long as we can do
away with the people who are saying the
stuff that's so bad right it's like how
um
how superficial does your conceptual
understanding of freedom of speech have
to be for you to misunderstand that
there's a problem and that we have to
protect speech that we do not like in
order to protect speech that we need to
hear oh my God yeah okay so I got two
more from this okay cool good
um three key steps forward
the AMA House of delegates representing
every state and Specialty also adopted a
comprehensive strategy to address
health-related disinformation spread by
health professionals of the 2022 annual
meeting
they've got a number of them the second
of three main bullet points is
that the ABA House of delegates include
intends to quote address the
dissemination and monetization of
disinformation by health professionals
via social media platforms
they're going to address the
monetization of disinformation right
they're going to address the
monetization and
um I'm I'm afraid I have to bring this
up uh this emerged in my world at least
very shortly before today's podcast
um but I have now sourced the proposed
not even proposed the policy change that
will go into effect November 3rd at
PayPal oh what what PayPal is going to
do is they are going to on a per
instance basis a per violation basis
they are going to Avail themselves of
the right to take twenty five hundred
dollars out of your PayPal account if
you and then you can imagine all of the
things that you're not allowed to do
including uh say things that uh support
the oppression uh based on gender
identity
um
Etc and misinformation so imagine yeah
go ahead that's kind of all I got uh huh
PayPal isn't a platform that people put
their voices onto PayPal is a payment
platform so
do you remember remember when Sargon of
akkad got
deep platform by patreon this would have
been like
end of 2018 maybe yes I do okay that's
the basis of things on the basis of
things he said in like a private video
on YouTube that had nothing to do with
patreon absolutely I think I got that
right yep okay so
um and it doesn't matter what he was
saying it doesn't matter I don't I don't
even remember at this point right
doesn't matter
patreon shut down his patreon account
because he said something over there yep
that they didn't like
PayPal isn't actually even a media
company so any like any time you say
anything in your world that they decide
they don't like they could find you
twenty five hundred dollars well I tried
to suss this out because I agree it's
conspicuous that it isn't even like
patreon where you could say something on
patreon or on some thing that you were
funding through patreon right where
patreon could convince itself that it
had a right to do such a thing
PayPal I think does not even have a
place there's not a community that they
could be discussing so it must be your
larger social media life that they are
intending to police by and you know of
course as is always the case in these uh
overreaches uh authoritarian overreaches
by these platforms
what is written as ambiguous
and it would be one thing if there were
a mechanism to adjudicate whether you
had in fact or had not in fact violated
their Rule and whether in fact their
rule was clear enough to even follow it
if that's what you intended to do right
there is no venue and so what that
affected if you were doing anything
wrong I'm sure you wouldn't have gotten
find well here's the problem is that all
of these policies pretend to be
indifferent to who you are and they are
exactly the opposite right this policy
totally will be wielded against people
with certain beliefs and it will not be
wielded against people with other
beliefs and in this case it has
Financial teeth as uh Helen that's huge
so uh it was uh
Ian Michael Chong miles miles Chong who
alerted us to this on Twitter today and
I only briefly looked at what he had
pointed to and then Helen Dale responded
to him and asked does that mean that if
there's nothing in your PayPal account
that they could go to your bank accounts
which are connected now I honestly think
that that is not spelled out in this
document it's not clear one way or the
other but we even have to worry about
interacting with PayPal
even beyond what might be in our PayPal
accounts because they do have these
agreements that we've signed up for to
link our accounts to other accounts that
we might have and so if you you know if
in a podcast that PayPal decides it has
the right to police you've said 11
things that it sees as violations
how much of your wealth are they allowed
to drain and where do you get to
challenge this it's you know it's some
company that you've clicked okay on its
terms of service
so this is this is absolutely
um a declaration of war right by and I
would also point out that if the world
worked anything like it is supposed to
work
PayPal would be bending over backwards
to be indifferent to what the people who
use its service say or think right it is
a for-profit corporation
its interests involve getting as many
people to use its Service as much as
possible right that's what's in the
interest of its shareholders not
becoming the nanny Corporation that's
going to go and search what you say to
figure out if you're violating its terms
of service right that is an aggressive
actually that's that's a very
interesting that's a sort of an
interesting turnaround because part of
part of why we find ourselves in the
predicament we find ourselves in
society-wide is that people mistake
oh it's a pharmaceutical company it must
be interested in your health
um the mistake like the type of
organization it is for actually what its
fiscal responsibility is and like no
their fiscal responsibility is actually
to make more money for their for their
shareholders and you are arguing that
you know in like a reversal here that
PayPal is actually failing in its fiscal
responsibility if it is going to start
going after some considerable fraction
of its um the formal audience and I I
don't know I honestly don't know what to
make of this but we see business after
business
cannibalizing its core competency over
political ideology yeah it is bizarre as
hell right Twitter even if Twitter has
deeply held beliefs Twitter as a
business should be absolutely interested
in getting everybody to use the service
independent of what it is they're trying
to say you wouldn't expect a company
that makes Paper to suddenly start
trying to Nanny who can buy it to write
what on it you want them you would
imagine that that company would be
exactly the opposite that they would be
trying to ignore all of the Despicable
things that are being written on the
paper that they produce so they can sell
more of it right why are these
businesses going after their core
competencies why are they throwing off
users who actually represent Revenue
right why is this happening across
multiple Industries now yeah right it's
it's a genuine mystery and you know it
could have lots of different answers it
could be that these things have been
captured from the inside and the terror
of being torn apart by these political
ideologies that uh you know have control
over the levers internal to these
corporations is causing them to
cannibalize their audience
um you know in fear the same way
universities have upended their
truth-seeking mission out of fear of you
know a motivated mob that's possible
it's also possible it's something else
yeah it is
um well I'm I'm thrown that's well huge
thank goodness it is November 3rd
because
um this policy doesn't go into effect
until then so yeah small favors okay um
gives us time to find an alternative to
PayPal I guess
okay one more quote from this uh this
letter
from the president of the American
Medical Association published on October
5th so the headline of which is turning
the tide against medical disinformation
will take all of us SEC at this point if
you received that link from me or not
uh oh now you gay you just okay so be
prepared not just yet
but almost so here's but here's a
paragraph from a little bit earlier I
can show a picture
okay just don't not yet okay uh I
recently he this is Dr Resnick the
president of the AMA
writing I recently participated in an
annual fact checking Festival
let me just read that again I recently
participated in an annual fact checking
Festival hosted by media organizations
pointer and PolitiFact called the United
facts of America
where I explain the impact of unchecked
medical misinformation to a diverse
audience of journalists policy makers
and pundits and also the responsibility
Physicians have in policing it
an annual fact checking Festival so I'm
I'm we're going to talk about festivals
actually because this got me thinking
again about festivals and what they are
and are not in fact checking and
Festival don't go together in fact but I
recently went to an accounting Fest
conference you could call it a
conference we have a word for that a
fact-checking festival
um
okay now Zach if you would show
a second okay well I'm going to read
from the site that I am now at the
um United facts of America a festival of
fact checking
it was on May 10th through 13th and the
headline news
join us for the sub headline join us
live
join us live on May 10-13 for a virtual
Festival of fact checking with Dr
Anthony fauci
wow there it is there it is wow and one
more
um
they have the ticket prices the VIP
experience members of politifacts Truth
Squad are offered discounted tickets
is that a fact
that's right it's the United States of
America how could that be a fact
so let's say I think we're not I will
link to this in the show notes and all
of these things and you'll you which is
not a joke it's not a joke it is not a
joke it happened the now president of
the AMA is pointing to this with Glee in
his uh op Aries whatever it is letter
from three days ago
um get tickets now to access four days
of forward-thinking conversation about
the role of fact in our lives this
virtual fast virtual Festival even wow
this virtual Festival is for everyone
interested in fact based expression
Civic engagement and the role of facts
in a free Society come celebrate facts
with us
oh and and uh and Anthony fauci is the
facts are that's he's he's foxy that's
for sure oh my goodness yeah um oh also
oh so I also this sent me down a little
bit of rabbit hole I got no resolution
so thank you so much time on this but
over 10 hours of virtual program you'll
hear from expert fact Checkers from
PolitiFact The Washington Post and
factcheck.org just like
do you go to school to become an extra
fines expert piece in fact checking how
do you do that I get no resolution
actually Google failed me I spent you
know not a long time but you know 20
minutes like okay what what makes an
expert fact Checker an expert or a fact
Checker in fact I have my very first sub
stack I went after PolitiFact for being
Facebook's arm of
of misinformation frankly but this
phrase now is showing up all over the
place expert fact Checker expert Factor
expert
says who this this is very much like Jon
Stewart saying well the AMA says well
and the president of the AMA went to
this virtual Festival of fact checking
where fauci was so we know that's all
good I have the solution to you okay
because no I don't I got it all right
here it is yeah
the solution
is proper spelling and it works like
this
do you remember back
where the concept remember how we
started the show right oh yeah I'm I'm
trying to um redeem yourself redeem
myself and redeem r e d e a m but it's
close it's okay everyone knows what you
mean
well I feel my job is done here
um no here it is you remember back in I
don't know was it the 90s oh God when uh
the term fat speciated and there was a
traditional fat f-a-t and then there was
p-h-a-t I wouldn't have never thought of
it as species before but yeah sure it
was it was good website or Genesis sure
okay it is time we now the the Gap
straddled by the concept of fact is so
large that it must now or not fat or
fact yes yes we now need fact p-h-a-c-t
yes exactly that's these fact Checkers
pH AC Festival of facts of facts exactly
and now if that's true if we can Define
these things based on whether or not you
were accused of being fat or p-a-t-t a a
t i I actually know yeah you caught that
one yeah
um if you know as in that case we can
distinguish facts from Facts in this
case by the way they are spelled then
what makes a good fact checker
is the ability to straddle the largest
gap from the actual fact you know things
that are you know true right to what is
being claimed as a fact
p-h-a-c-t right the bigger the Gap you
can cover
right where you can claim that the p h a
c t is in fact just simply true when it
is the farthest distance from what is
actually true then that puts you at a
high status within the realm of the PHA
CT Checkers right and you're probably
getting by into all the pH estables
right exactly yeah yeah and um and the
rest of us can tell you to p h u c k r
from them gladly yeah
okay uh this actually is perfect because
um I think we also now need
Festival p-h-e-s-t-i-v-a-l
um but they had a fact-checking festival
which in fact had no relationship to as
far as I could tell facts or presumably
festivities in any way
uh and I have been wanting for several
weeks to come back to Barbara Aaron Rick
who died in the very beginning of
September as we were sort of mid-move
and I and I couldn't find my copy of
um one of her excellent books dancing in
the streets at that time so we just
spent a little bit of time talking about
her
um and this this is perfect because
dancing in the streets a history of
collective Joy
uh it's a 2006 book it's a book that I
actually uh used in my in some of my
curriculum when I was teaching with a
linguist we were teaching um both animal
and human communication and she Aaron
Reich
um you know much missed
uh we so we mentioned her in live stream
140 and then also a year before that in
live stream 95.
so it turns out but I want to share two
excerpts from from this book dancing in
the streets uh beginning just the very
beginning of chapter one in which she
effectively defends the idea of Festival
of actual festival
and this chapter one is called the
archaic roots of ecstasy and it's
a page and a half or so here let's see
if I can find it
and then a much shorter a very short
excerpt from later on in the book to
give us a little food for thought as if
we need more okay I can't find
I did I did use one of my fancy book
darts there we go okay they are care
groups of ecstasy from chapter one of
dancing in the streets the history of
collective Joy by
um newly departed Barbara Aaron wreck
go back 10 000 years and you will find
humans toiling away at the many mundane
activities required for survival hunting
food Gathering making weapons and
garments beginning to experiment
agriculture but if you land on the right
moonlit night or seasonal Turning Point
you might also find them engaged in what
seems by comparison to be a gratuitous
waste of energy dancing in lines or
circles sometimes wearing masks are what
appear to be costumes often waving
branches or sticks
most likely both sexists would be
dancing each in its separate line or
Circle
their faces and bodies might be painted
with red ocher or so archaeologists
guess from the widespread presence of
that colored ore the sites of human
settlements the scene in other words
might not be too different from these
Savage rituals encountered by 19th
century westerners among native peoples
of the world
we can infer these scenes from
prehistoric rock art depicting dancing
figures which has been discovered at
sites in Africa India Australia Italy
turkey Israel Iran and Egypt among other
places
whatever else they did our distant
ancestors seemed to find plenty of time
for the kinds of activities the
Anthropologist Victor Turner described
as liminal or peripheral to the main
business of life
festive dancing was not a rare
incidental subject for prehistoric
artists the Israeli archaeologist Joseph
garfinkel asserts that dancing scenes
quote were our most popular indeed
almost the only subject used to describe
interaction between people and the
Neolithic and chocolatic periods when
such danced rituals originated as not
known but there is evidence they may go
back well into the Paleolithic era or
Stone Age
at one recently discovered site in
England drawings on the ceiling of a
cave show Conga lines of female dancers
along with drawings of animals like
bison and Ibex which are known to have
become extinct in England 10 000 years
ago
so well before people had a written
language and possibly before they took
up a settled lifestyle they danced and
understood dancing as an activity
important enough to record on Stone
it is not easy to read the excitement of
a danced ritual into prehistoric
drawings the figures are highly stylized
many of those cataloged by garfinkel are
little more than stick figures or
Silhouettes few possess facial features
or anything like a facial expression
even the identification of them as
dancers take some interpretive work the
figures have to be using their limbs in
ways not associated with normal
activities holding their arms up holding
hands in a circle raising their legs or
leaping for example
yet even in these crude two-dimensional
depictions some of the recognizable
ingredients of more festive recent of
more recent festive Traditions shine
through masking and costuming for
example
some of the male figures wear masks in
the form of animal heads or abstract
designs other dancers wear what
archaeologists interpret as costumes
such as leverage skims in the clearest
sign of motion and possibly excitement
some of the figures have long flowing
hair standing up from their heads as if
they are moving rapidly and tossing
their heads to some long silenced drum
beat
clearly danced rituals did not seem like
a waste of energy to prehistoric peoples
they took the time to Fashion masks and
costumes they wantingly expended
calories in the execution of the dance
they preferred to record these scenes
over any other group activity thus
Anthropologist Victor Turner's
Consignment of danced ritual to an
occasional marginal or liminal status
seems especially unwarranted in the
prehistoric case and more representative
of the production-oriented mentality of
her own Industrial Age than a
prehistoric priorities
surely this people knew hardship and
were often threatened by food shortages
disease and wild animals but ritual of a
danced and possibly ecstatic nature was
Central to their lives
perhaps only because our own lives so
much easier in many ways are also so
constrained by the imperative to work we
have to wonder why
fantastic fantastic yeah she's she's
brilliant uh and the whole I record I
recommend the whole book as a history of
sort of
ecstatic ritual and and festival and
you know would say embodied engagement
with other individuals in real time and
space is Festival
put virtual in front of it and it's no
Festival put fact checking in front of
it and you're really far afield and you
can use words any way you want because
the first amendment does guarantee us
that
but it doesn't mean what you think it
does yeah it really doesn't
so
um later in the book
halfway through or so
she builds a compelling argument and
it's not one that she is certain of and
she quotes various historians but posits
is a real possibility that apparently
there's a fair amount of historical
evidence for a rise in what we Now
understand to be depression but what
would have been called Melancholia in
um
in early modern times and like the the
Middle Ages and um and even the
Renaissance
uh and she posits that the rise in
Melancholia the rise in depression may
be connected to The Disappearance of
traditional festivities specifically
Festival
and she points to various historians
discussion of the rise of subjectivity
and the discovery of the inner self
and she summarizes several concrete
changes that occurred in the early
modern period first among the upper
middle class because these were things
that took some money and then
um
and and then of course came into all of
our worlds and helped create this modern
idea of the individual as a walled
Fortress which answers neither to others
nor the laws of nature that ladder bit
being my addition so here's what she
says there's historical evidence
um of shifts in the early modern period
um mirrors in which to examine oneself
became popular among those who could
afford them along with self-portraits
Rembrandt painted over 50 of them and
autobiographies in which to revise and
elaborate the image that one has
projected to others in Bourgeois homes
public spaces that guests may enter are
differentiated for the first time from
the private spaces bedrooms for example
in which one may retire to let down
one's guard and truly be oneself more
decorous form more decorous forms of
entertainment plays and operas requiring
people to remain immobilized each in his
or her separate seat began to provide an
alternative to the promiscuously
interactive and physically engaging
pleasures of Carnival
wow yeah so she's got really mirrors
self-portraits autobiographies the
separation of public from private spaces
within your own structure and a movement
from entertainment in which you are
physically embodied and and moving and
interacting to one in which you are
mostly still and receptive
so they're really two things in there as
I see it one is a sort of uh precursor
to the obsession with uh image that
social media then brings yes right
there's very much sense of your public
self and your private self yes
um being potentially very very different
and that to me ties back to the
transgender stuff
that that we we have people who are so
concerned with their sense of self that
what they actually are takes a vaccine
right and then the second thing in there
uh something uh I've pointed to the
radical shift in our relationship with
music in particular maybe all art but
music in particular where we become
consumers of something that every single
human being would have been a producer
of until fairly recently or at least
interacting with like even if not
everyone
drummed or sang or you know played a
string instrument
um everyone would have been dancing with
the music at some point I I believe
there's actually no no distinction there
that every single person every single
healthy person would have participated
in the group of Music
um the scene yep singing dancing
uh otherwise keeping time
and the idea of oh we're very compelled
by music right it drives us we want it
but we want to consume it it's somebody
else's product and it's foreign to us
and some of us can't produce it right
yeah it's a very odd relationship
and it's a new one so anyway I I don't
see them as exactly the same thing but I
do think she's pointing to a radical
change in our relationship to the entire
uh realm uh
and it's a really
it's a really subtle and important point
and can you imagine
someone at carnival which we have
interacted with some
in Ecuador and I in Panama as well
um or one of these older rights from say
Greece
which became you know ecstatic in the
original sense of the word can you
imagine any of any such people
being invited
to the pointer institute's fact-checking
Festival
eager for a festival that wasn't
otherwise on the calendar and arriving
and finding
well reason for Melancholia honestly
right like I you know the the hypothesis
that as Festival as interactive
engagement with your body and your
community on a regular basis at regular
moments as seasons change at regular
holidays became less and less a part of
the world so too did Melancholia
increase I like this as a hypothesis
very much yeah no it's uh
and I Anthony fauci is just the cherry
on top of that Sunday I mean the idea
that at a fact checking Festival a guy
who is literally out loud said and then
not been horrified that he made some
sort of error that to contradict him is
to contradict science I mean yep I am
science I am science
yeah ignore the man behind the vaccine
um yeah it's
well I don't know words used to mean
something it was cool when they did
because you can use them for stuff but
here's
here's to a re-upping a real Festival
all right yeah and um
the president of the AMA referring
delightedly to this virtual fact-facing
fact [ __ ]
fact checking Festival
um
suggests that he may not really know
what other festivals or facts are
that's it yeah that's uh that's that's
mind-blowing I cannot believe that
that's not a joke
this turns out to be a joke we will have
to accept okay
yes and great you know please please
on the other hand guys it supposedly
happened in May
and uh
I imagine some people were there who uh
can can vouch for the fact that it I
mean it's not even there though it's
virtual so I imagine a bunch of people
were sitting in front of their screens
feeling super festive about this whole
thing oh so festive so festive but I
have to say in in an era of
p-h-a-c-t-s what does it mean that it
happened at some moment and is now over
right or that it was virtual right it
can change it can be anything it needs
to have been yeah it was virtual and now
it's and now it wasn't virtual right oh
i i s oh I see your point yeah I mean
let's put it this way it is a it is a
festival of safety and Effectiveness in
the truest
is there some other way to spell true
um
t-r-u-s t-r-o-o how about
t-r-o-o-s-t sense of that term yeah the
truest truest exactly
um yeah Zach is not pleased with us okay
okay
um
did you want to talk
about either cars or
um or yeah I had two things I had two
things we could
save one of them we've been going quite
a while it's two and I don't I've
started almost on time let's start with
the um
let's start with the uh the observation
I wanted to make
um and actually my friend Jared strodt
uh who I was uh very close with in high
school uh deserves a shout out here
because
um anyway what this is I don't know
what's coming now is a discussion of a
life hack it is one that I think our
listeners ought to consider at least
before rejecting
and it works like this
um my friend Jared used to love in the
winter now mind you you were in L.A we
grew up in La so the winter was less
brutal than I don't know what's coming
but well Jared used to after he had a
car he used to like to roll down all of
the wind that he had a a a a car with a
sunroof but it was a manual sunroof and
he used to vigorously open the manual
sunroof and roll down all the windows I
think they might have manned it down he
manned the windows down and the sunroof
open and would drive around with the
heat on
which
was
odd nobody did this the sunroof open
yeah oh I do this all the time it's
wonderful yeah now here here's the thing
I will just say without any further uh
analysis that it is actually
quite the Innovation you don't think of
it because in general what we do as
moderns is we try to perfect the
temperature of our environment so that
we are comfortable right we're trying to
be efficient in our use of resources yes
although I would point out that the heat
in your car is free or very close to it
so this is an important point this is
explain that further so the point is
that your card generates too much that
this is
ridiculously wasted even if it was
wasteful I'd still be an advocate for it
okay but but it's nice but at least in a
gas car yeah it's and that's true the
logic of this does invert yeah a little
bit in a in a electric car but electric
cars are so marvelously efficient anyway
but
um but the point is that the the heat is
is just recovered from what is being
generated by the end right the engine is
generating far too much heat for
anybody's good all the time and even in
LA right and in fact
um back in the day when cars weren't
quite so good
um those of us
who were a little Adventure he knew that
if your car was in danger of overheating
if you were in the desert for example
and it was very very hot and your car
was showing if the temperature gauge
which cars used to have showed that you
were in danger of uh boiling over and
melting your head gasket and all sorts
of terrible things it could happen to
you one of the remedies was you would
turn the heat on you know our producers
had like all of these things happening
well of course he has a young man he
pushes limits and he's blown out a head
gasket or two but two cars on the same
Mountain
that mountain is probably trying to tell
you something but in any case the point
is it is not your instinct in in a a hot
car in danger of overheating to turn the
heat on but it's exactly what you should
do because it effectively adds a second
radiator to the vehicle it blows the
heat into the
car which is not fun but but you know
when you want to open your windows in
that case right in that case you
definitely want to open your windows but
in the winter
opening your windows and your sunroof if
you've got one and um
turning on the heat
at just at the level of the experience
actually is quite interesting right it
creates a kind of swirling mixture of
hot and cold that is very invigorating
and anyway it's it's something I've been
doing for some time
um both our sons now engage in this
behavior and it um
let's put it this way
there was a time when all cars did not
have air conditioners
right they all had heaters for obvious
reasons because the Heat's generated
automatically but it used to be that air
conditioners were an option
um now that air conditioners are
effectively on every new car at least in
the US
people in general if you watch people
driving around they almost always have
their windows up right you drive around
in this sealed box and you get the
temperature to be as you like it and you
do so without thinking about the
possibility that you have a choice and
that maybe what you actually want is a
higher variance experience in other
words are you more comfortable at a
level of temperature consistency or does
the fact that you net out to a
temperature that's comfortable but it's
in a swirling mass of warm and cold air
and of course if you have heated seats
you can add another element to this you
can you know drive around with no heat
coming in a heated seat and the windows
open anyway it's something that gives
you a lot more
sense of of your drive so I have two two
reasons that this is not all that
appealing to me yep one is that I have
long hair right and you talk about the
swirling mass of cold and warm air uh
well your your hair stays more or less
in place and you talk about it you know
showing signs of having been in such a
car afterwards but it never ends up
restricting your vision or getting
tangled into knots right so
um our producer who has not had a
haircut in a long time but does not have
hair the length of mine has something to
say Foundation of Windows that you can
have open that we can
lead in place but it may be front left
and back right it may you have to you do
have to so what's that it does not it
doesn't allow you to retain
the hair that you walked into the car
with still having at the other end I'm
not arguing the other second point is
sound is noise well I was going to get
it and uh you know if maybe if you're
listening to music you can just crank it
up and you're not going to get some of
the trouble bits so much
um but if you're listening to words like
I've been listening to a lot of
audiobooks lately it's going to be
really tough to hear right over the
noise
it also depends like are you talking
about at highway speed you're talking
about 80 miles an hour well there's a
lot of caveats that I haven't gotten to
yeah one is you have to think about the
quality of your air and frankly I don't
know you're outside right if you're on a
highway if you're on a freeway right you
are in a corridor of a mixture of air
and exhaust totally how good for you is
it to have the windows open I don't know
because if your windows aren't open but
your vents are open it may be that
you're breathing the same stuff right or
it may be that there's some rate at
which your air in the car goes bad as
you get on the highway I don't know what
those considerations are but they're
certainly worth thinking about if you
are on a lonely Country Road it's a very
different phenomenon as far as sound
goes I think there's even a worse caveat
not only does it get in the road from
the point of view of listening to
whatever you're listening to but it may
be a danger to your hearing it's really
loud it's so if you're going fast it's
really loud especially if the surface
you're on isn't totally um Smith yep and
in part it depends on your vehicle right
a vehicle that is very well thought out
with respect to turbulence near your
ears may be a lot quieter with the
windows open the vehicle it isn't so
well thought out not so much I will say
from uh taking up motorcycle riding that
the danger to one's hearing posed by
wind noise is a big topic of discussion
in the motorcycle world and helmets
block some of that now yep and helmets
vary tremendously in quality one of the
things that I think it's absolutely
worth spending hundreds extra on a
helmet for is one that blocks much
higher quantity of the noise but no
helmet is thought to render it safe and
so the advice is that you wear
earplugs in addition those little foam
the foam ones are lousy there are better
ones but yes that you're supposed to
wear something if you're if you're going
to be at highway speeds you're supposed
to wear something in addition to your
helmet and so I don't know that driving
around with your windows open in the car
is safe for your are hearing it's worth
considering I'd love to know if somebody
has looked at the decibel levels
undoubtedly they have but in any case
the point I want to make though is that
we have defaulted into
two things we have defaulted into
writing in closed cars there are lots of
reasons to question that right it uh
divorces you from the distance that
you're traveling in a way that isn't
obvious to you if you always have the
windows closed
um you know when we were in Portland uh
the beginning of this summer and summer
came late
I began to say I think it was just a
couple of people who had actual
convertibles like there's a Miata and I
don't remember what the other one was
um who were driving around with their
convertibles as convertibles in like
April and there was like there was a
freak snowstorm in April it was not
convertible weather and I so respected
it it's like okay you're just you're
feeling it you're here you are and you
know these were people on the highway
this is going around town and you know
it's pretty low low noise yep low speed
um you know it's it's always a risk the
Pacific Northwest except for maybe in
August September it might start pouring
on you at any moment but well you know
it's more of a risk in a convertible I
will say that the more I do this you
know I do it in the winter and
um
one definitely has the sense of very
chilly air but you don't you're not net
chilly right well there's a lot I mean I
think maybe we'll we'll come back to
this I think maybe your intention was to
come back to this question of sort of
thermoregulation yep uh but
you know cold plunges cold showers cold
sleeping you know all of these things
where you shock your body into something
that modernity has rendered us
um able to fully Escape yeah most
moderns never actually have to be
shocked by cold anymore and it's quite
possible that being occasionally or even
fairly regularly shocked by Cold
um in a way that you know that you can
get out of it safely may actually be
extraordinarily good for you yeah that
this is kind of where I'm headed here is
that
because our ancestors were as Aaron
Wright points out
um stressed for resources yeah we have a
built-in obsession with things like
thermal comfort that results in us
taking the variance out of our
environments at a level that uh
is
probably not good for you and the ways
in which it may not be good for you are
a little hard to
um to Define fully and I would say one
thing that is true is that I do have the
sense
that driving around with the heat on and
the windows open
gives you a sense of being alive and I
would say that in general the sense of
driving around with the windows closed
is almost the opposite right you can
drive and just almost not be cognizant
that you're even doing it if you're on a
familiar Road and that the question is
you know maybe there are psychological
benefits to introducing thermal chaos
into a otherwise mundane activity and in
any case I think the upshot of all of
this is
hey you whoever you are this is a very
cheap experiment are you overlooking
something that would enhance your life
you could find out in a couple of drives
and it might be that it changes nothing
about what you do or it might be that it
changes everything about what you do and
um what do you have to lose
awesome okay
um did you want to go to your other item
today you want to say it for next time
um I think it's probably best saved for
next time all right excuse me
huh
well then
we're gonna take a break and we'll be
back with a q a we'll be back next week
eight days from now same time different
day probably same place
so 12 30 Pacific on Sunday that'll be
October 16th must be given how math
Works yes
um
you know math doesn't have to work that
way given the invention of
phatts no no no okay no
oh we can we can re we can spell math
differently m-e-t-h
all right
[Applause]
I went too far no I'm aware that I did
oh you're it's
fine I mean
I feel like the world forced you to it
thank you yes the world did force me to
it I don't know if it portion of that
particular one but yeah I like to think
it did I I feel better about it if
that's what happened okay
so we're gonna take a break we'll be
back uh ask your questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com
uh any logistical questions you have
uh
you can send darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com you can find us on our
patreons
uh and um boy I feel like there was
something else I was supposed to say at
the end of the hour here but I've
forgotten
so
until next time because of the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]